what we got here what do we go this is
some kind of weird right it's kind of
like a bowl kind of like a ball we're
like well maybe more like a arm like a
dog food yeah a dog food dish right
because they've got strainer just kind
of right and then you've got this
hollowed out part in the middle right
because the green part that's the area
that I'm actually retained to get Duvall
view right so that part is solid the
inside part that the carved out bit the
inner volume that bit is empty ok so
again I've got it out of volume and an
inner volume right now this out of olive
view is nice and easy because I've got
some straight edges here right the outer
volume is just a cylinder very good ok
so PI R squared H I know what the radius
of this cylinder is because I got zero
to hear I don't yet know what the height
is what is the height it's good before
right because when you put an x equals 2
here to get this part you get 2 squared
which is four that's great so I've got
pi times two squared times for that
gives me 16 pi outside bit done ok so
you don't need to do that by integration
right and in the same way that if you
get given some of you have asked me this
some of you even asked something like
this for instance I think this is the
exact one I got asked just now people
look at this and they're like oh gross
perfect to differentiate that is a bit
messy because of that x squared minus x
squared the middle to integrate it is
the same in fact at the moment you don't
have the tools yet to integrate this guy
you will eventually but remember right
this is actually just a semicircle all
right in fact this particular semi
circle has radius to set center of the
origin so this is the area in question
so being that an integral like this
tells you area you just need the area of
a quadruped and be that this like this
integral is just tell you a volume you
can just use a volume for you it's fine
there's the other one foot to the other
one this takes a little work not much
though ok I'll integrating with respect
to Y because that's the access I'm
rotating around ok so being though
integrating with respect to Y I need
offer a low batteries for y which are
04 very good that's an easy thing to
myths right um you didn't even get that
force applied to you a lot of people
just c02 babe they'll integrate which
demonstrates they don't understand
what's going on here this kind of
looking at the numbers that are there
just plugging them in blown room but you
guys know better free then I've got my
integrated here this is going to be pi x
squared dy dy because I'm rotating
around this axis what is x squared in
this case it's just white alright that's
x squared dy yeah x squared is just wide
enough so this also is a very easy
primitive to state I've got that pie out
the front why is going to integrate up
into y square on to yet half Y squared
that's fine from naught to 4 i'm going
to pull that up dividing by 2 out the
front and this gives me 16 take away 0
yeah so this is a pie okay now I've
evaluated all the integrals right so now
I'm just like where i was before to get
the actual volume therefore i just take
the difference okay so it's just 16 pi
take away pi which gives me this result
it doesn't seem like it's the same
no yeah this is really interesting I
actually um looked at this and I was
like huh kind of weird right that this
number should be the same as that number
I hope that was a little suspicious and
so I thought I wonder why that is now
you can actually prove just for a bit of
fun right that if you take this parabola
okay and no matter how why do you make
your base no matter how I have you make
your base the volume of the actual thing
that you get the dog bowl as it were is
going to be exactly the same as the
volume of what you carve out to make the
dog bowl those two volumes are always
identical very easy to prove actually
the UM I took one through four five six
light okay and in fact the six lines
you've mostly done all of them is just a
minor modification you can make if you
want to extend yourself but that's it
like getting a difference to your
village is not complicate just work out
what what is and what the other is
carefully just from saving up you did
just make a dog bowl by the way I looked
at this and I was like I recognize this
shape um I don't know if anyone knows
this is the largest radio telescope in
the world right now basically what it is
because of the reflective properties of
a parabola is it so it's exactly this
it's exactly this it's this 3d parabolic
shape that's been dug into the ground
right and they've got all this sentiment
around it so that it actually stays
before okay this is the actual volume
that you've turned it so how much
concrete was required to well there you
go you can work it out if you so choose